this morning we're revealing how the
social media giant instagram
is changing the way it attempts to
protect teenagers on the app
back in 2019 researchers say at least 20
percent of children reported being
contacted
by an online predator and an estimated
500 000
predators are online every single day we
spoke with parents about how
they fear for their children's safety on
the internet
absolutely there's fears of predators i
mean
having that conversation constantly that
we don't give out personal information
we don't give out our location they do
get direct messages sometimes but if
they keep their profile
private it's generally not as risky as
some of the other ones
but we do you know we do still keep tabs
on it because
you know there are all of my daughters
get you know unsolicited
inquiries on on instagram to follow them
and then they're sort of left on their
own to make this decision should i let
this person follow me
that they may not know and it's you know
you can't be in there every day looking
at who's following them
instagram and all the other social media
places
they need to do a little more a little
bit more is i know technology is going
fast and everything is evolving but they
have the tools to do that
and and maybe they need to invest a
little more money a little bit more
education
online or whatever they can do to help
us as parents
well instagram is announcing now it will
use artificial
intelligence to restrict adults from
messaging teenagers if they don't
already follow each other it will also
use prompts to encourage
teens to be cautious and make it harder
for adults to find
and follow teens instagram will also
update its guide for parents
we've got instagram's head of global
public policy programs carolyn merrill
joining us now first on cbs this morning
to talk about all this
uh carolyn clearly this is a very big
deal good morning to you thank you for
being here um
i am curious from where you're sitting
how big of a problem
was online predators contacting teens
and why did you decide to announce these
changes now
thank you so much for having me keeping
young people safe
on instagram is hugely important to us
and it's something that we've taken
seriously since the very beginning of
instagram
just last year alone we announced new
tools like nudges
restrict comment filtering all under the
umbrella of protecting
teens so this is just the latest in one
of our suites of tools to protect teens
why we wanted to do it now again this is
something that we take seriously
but we wanted to really get ahead and
ahead of
an upstream and protect teens from
unwanted interactions between adults and
teens
to those numbers that we cited earlier
that really jump out to me 500
000 predators online every day does that
match up with what you guys monitor
internally so
on a whole we see that people come to
instagram to connect with their family
and friends and to find
communities and those interactions are
genuinely extremely positive and safe
even in one of our latest reports we saw
that in over 10 000 pieces of content
five were potentially risky for teens
but five is too much
and that's why we're investing in even
more technology to protect teens
so you're supposed to be 13 years old or
older to be able to create an instagram
account but as i discovered recently
when my 11 year old decided to follow me
and then i checked his followers and it
was all the other 11 year olds
that he knows uh clearly there's not age
verification
people can enter whatever they want if
i'm understanding this new program
correctly you're now going to have
in essence age verification through
artificial intelligence is that right
so you have to be 13 to use instagram
and we ask for age when you first sign
on
we also rely on reporting tools so if
you see someone that's not 13
you can report and we'll take that
account down and we're using machine
learning to look at behavioral
signals of how old someone is to make
sure that we're
also getting ahead of that to make sure
that 13 and over
is what's allowed hey carolyn a lot is
focused on the age 13 but when do you
think a child is
instagram ready outside of their age
13 is a good place to start but we also
understand that this is really personal
and every teen is different and so in
our updated parents guide
you can go and find different tools and
conversation starters for parents
to have with their teens to see when is
that teen ready
and then even when they're on the
platform what is that experience going
to be like and how can you set your team
up to have the most intentional
safe positive experience while you're
there well we all have an interest in
intentional safe positive experiences
online so we all have an interest in
this effort succeeding
uh it's a big new day at instagram
carolyn merrell thank you very much for
sharing it with us
thanks for having me